congressman Devin Nunez is right in the
middle of all this he's the ranking
Republican on the house Intel committee
and he joins this tank former chairman
of it country thanks so much for coming
on it's great to be with you do you
believe this explanation no no so he
looks ship six explanation yes
absolutely so it looks from the
perspective of people on the outside
like Adam shifts office guided this
complaint like it was a setup well and
it looks like he knew something
beforehand because you know this was in
the press then you had tweets you had
stories written by no infusion gps
reporters and then you fast forward he
had a couple times that he could have
told us in private that this had
happened okay now nothing by law makes
him he doesn't have to tell us but he
clearly gave no indication that he had
ever met with the whistleblower or hit
anybody on his team had ever met with a
whistleblower I mean that's the real
issue here two opportunities I'm talking
to opportunities behind closed doors and
he didn't tell us so this is not you
know one among many stories this is the
basis for the impeachment of the
President of the United States and so
it's not a small thing it's the opposite
of that
how can any of us have confidence that
this isn't just a pure partisan
invention yeah well well it is a
partisan adventure and it's not a real
impeachment the way that impeachment
process has worked the other times has
been used okay I just came from the
Capitol and we had I mean nine hours of
ambassador Volker which if you listen to
the mainstream media and the Democrats
this was gonna be the guy that was gonna
give up all the goods on Rudy Giuliani
and because this was the special envoy
to Ukraine on behalf of the Trump
administration of course they went on
and on and on why did they keep going on
and on because they weren't getting what
they wanted I came in there at the end I
was I felt horrible for the for the man
I'm here he has he's been a public
servant he's getting married in a few
weeks and he just wants this to be done
with right and of course you know you
wouldn't know that by number one what
leaked out before his testimony and
what's leaked out ever since then so I I
have to ask you at the CIA since you
oversaw it you were in charge of the
oversight of the CIA and the other Intel
agencies is the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee
do you feel that our intelligence
agencies are properly over seen by the
Congress does the Congress does
democracy have control full control of
these agencies I think you could argue
over the FBI counterintelligence area
that started this investigation into the
Trump campaign No zero the FBI has not
cooperated throughout this investigation
perhaps with what the Attorney General
is doing running an investigation into
the beginnings of the Russia probe yes
with the CIA I think the challenge has
been and what we've what Republicans
have been pushing when you go on in the
hinterlands you got to remember these
are these agents put their lives on the
line okay the people that are out in the
field the challenge you have is there's
way too many intelligence officials and
and consultants and former agents and
now pontificating on networks that live
here in the swamp and look there's a
there's a reason to have a small cadre
of folks here in the spy get it but you
know and I can't give the number but I
can just tell you that a majority of
people are here in the swamp which is
not where they should be of course not
I'm a Jewish really I would think it's
about a majority yeah when you take when
you take the Department of Defense right
CIA DNI and all the other 17 if they're
hanging around the capital city of
course lobbying for lobbying for more
money for their programs and I'll tell
you one thing that's that people forget
you know I was the one ironically in the
spring of 16 when they were opening an
investigation into the Trump campaign
for colluding with Russians I went out
and said the biggest intelligence
failure since 9/11 was our inability to
understand Vladimir Putin's plans and
intentions in the spring of 2016
and of course you know what they did to
me the press corps in this town and the
Democrats yeah you were right you were
the right way I was the secret Russian
spy we're communicating I think in
Russian when we would meet secretly in
the park congressmen great to see you
thank you Thanks